The Joe Rogan Experience the day we got
the FBI later what was the FBI letter we
got FBI letter uh they sent the letter
to
priority records
saying they one guy was like I'm
you know
part of this department of the FBI and
we're very concerned with this record
called Straight Out of Compton you guys
got a song on there called [__] the
Police and we think this song could
encourage
um you know uh people to go against law
enforcement blah blah let us and blah
blah
um basically you know we'd like it if
you guys took it off the shelf you know
I'm saying to that tip so
you know they call us up there you know
they panicking
we don't know why they want us to kind
of just like man you got to come here we
gotta talk to you
or get up there and it's like pull out
this letter FBI
and we're like
it's like man do you know what this is
he's [__] agent he sent me this
letter and you know they was all like
nervous and [__] and we're looking like
a letter that's all you get you're not
gonna come in here and try to [__] with
us like they're not gonna you know what
I mean arrest us cuff us rough us up
none of that and we're like Y'all Scared
over a [__] letter
come back come back to South Central
with us you know I mean deal with the
sheriffs down there you know I mean they
do way more than give you a letter so we
felt that it was like
you know easy was like we're gonna be
big as [__] after this
but but the guys at the record company
this was the first time they ever dealt
with like pushback
first time the government probably even
knew they existed so they were freaked
out and we uh
we were like
okay we was looking for them to raid our
houses and [__] like damn because we
we're not seeing the battle Ram we're
not seeing them run up in people houses
on
dope charges whatever you know
especially in the late 80s early 90s
that's like they got a kick out of just
running up in people houses and [__] so
um
we were like looking for that to come
for the in the next you know next few
weeks we was looking like are they about
to hit us and it never happened so it
was like
what's the what's the issue what's the
problem it was just that letter and that
was it it's just that letter and then we
made the letter public
and they kind of just backed off and
[__] and then it became this big story
of you know the FBI hates this group I
think we was on the
cover like one of those you know New
York magazines and it was like
the FBI hates this group yeah look at
this yeah the FBI hates this man
wow yeah
easy was right yeah he was that's the
letter wow
look at that a song recorded by the rep
group NWA on their album entitled
Straight Outta Compton encourages
violence and disrespect for law
enforcement officer and has been brought
to my attention I understand your
company recorded and distributed this
album and I am writing to share my
thoughts and concerns with you
advocating violence and assault is wrong
and we in law enforcement Community take
the exception to such action violent
crimes a major problem in our country
reached an unprecedented high in 1988
78 law enforcement officers were
feloniously slain in the feloniously
slain the line of duty during 1988 four
more in 1987. law enforcement officers
dedicate their lives to protection of
our citizens recordings such as the one
from NWA are both discouraging and
degrading to these Brave dedicated
officers music is a significant role in
society and I'd want you to be aware of
the FBI's position relative to this song
and its message I believe my reviews
reflect the opinion of the entire law
enforcement community
huh yeah never met this dude nah nah
never interesting
yeah 1988 was a different world and that
was the first that was like the the
first
moment of that where the you know we had
heard that like the government and
politicians were concerned about rap
music
without a doubt um and then it just
you know they didn't come after me but
all these other different agencies was
starting to hit us up and
you know they were going they started
going after iced tea you know a little
bit because he
body count did a song called cop killer
and um
yeah you know it was It was a
it was a time when we grew up real fast
we had to understand that
you know this is bigger than hip-hop
um and we gotta we gotta stand up for
what we know is true and right
it's like we're not making [__] up you
know it's go down you know um
I've seen guys tell
cops you know I mean take off their gun
take off their badge and we can knuckle
it up in the streets and do it like men
and uh
so you know we knew that cinnamon was
out there where people was really like
yo
um
if you're not going if you're gonna act
like a thug you know I'm saying let's
Thug it out you know what I'm saying or
you're gonna act like an officer
then we'll we'll we'll you know um
you know
we'll respect your Authority you see
what I mean so it was a lot of cops that
we respected that came through that and
they would treat us like you know
real humans you know not like you know
suspects
you know I mean you don't want anybody
come through just treat you like a
suspect you ain't out here doing nothing
these dudes uh so we knew some dudes
that would come through and talk to us
tell us you know y'all need to watch
y'all be careful you know what I'm
saying and you know do anybody know
something that happened around the
corner and all these little stuff and we
like nah nah nah but they was respectful
and and we respected their Authority
then there was others that would come
through you know look at you crazy uh
harass you you know we was kids on the
bikes we saw one day they came like
eight nine years old man we on our bikes
got our bikes lay down we made a ramp we
all kicking on the grass resting looking
at our bikes like their [__]
motorcycles and [__] like you know and
um man shares hit get the corner came
all up on the grass
and like get against the car all that
you know [__] [__] with kids they
know we kids sitting on bikes man what
what you think we did you know what I'm
saying like rolling off my grass
yeah I mean what you think we out here
do
yeah yeah so what was it like when the
album came out like interacting with
cops
most of them was cool actually it's
almost like most of them said they
listened to this song
um
in the movie we get ran out of Detroit
like they ran us off stage because we
sung the song a lot of undercover police
you know throwing m80s and [__] on the
stairs yeah so we thought they were
shooting at us so we run off they catch
us they round us up and you know they
like
thought she was gonna come to Detroit
right talking that cop I mean that uh
[__] the police [__] and
can't come through Detroit talking that
and we should run you out of jail you
know I mean we should lock y'all up and
blah blah blah and we like listening we
listening and he said uh
but
if y'all got a couple pictures y'all got
a couple eight by tens y'all signing for
my daughter
[Music]
ain't gonna have no problems so
you know we was pissed but we was like
man easy was like getting t-shirts get
them everything they need come on come
on come on come on come on and so you
know we signed this [__] you know
reluctantly you know but the concert's
over yeah they they turned the concert
out yeah I mean they they ran us off
stage after
three songs and they got pictures and
then they got pictures and they got
autographs for their daughters and they
let us go they just said you can't come
to Detroit with that [__] wow so it
was only Detroit that was the only place
Cincinnati they ran us off really man
they would they would
they would uh have us they would before
every concert
the a sergeant or a captain or somebody
would come in
with a city ordinance
of what was obscene in their city in
their town and what could be said on
stage and what couldn't be said and if
you say any of this or doing it is we
will arrest you after your performance
wow
like what words
I mean [__] [__] really
um oh my gosh it's like the 1950s again
yeah it was like on that tip
um wow and this is 88 around there yeah
88.89 wow and we hit the stage
we like man we would tell the audience
you know what these [__] told
us backstage
they said we couldn't say [__] we
couldn't say [__] we couldn't say this
we couldn't say [__] you know I mean
we're gonna start this off with a [__]
is a [__] a [__] is a [__] you know
so um we would do our shows you know
sometimes they would just let us go
and then sometimes you would like after
the show you'd have to look and see the
looking like the security and everybody
face and you knew okay they honest so
many times
we we come off stage but then we like
switching jackets like people handy
jackets handing you different shirts and
[__] so you can put them on and walk
through the backstage because now cops
was like where where they at you know
where those guys that was on stage and
uh in Cincinnati I had to I saw him
coming I saw them all like looking
around and I didn't have a chance to
change my [__] so they was looking for
me and so uh I hit the exit I just I
went outside I went outside the concert
and it was people like
flowing in and out and uh it was like
cute what you doing out here I said man
they looking for me
he's like I jumped in the car with him
like fans
they drove me across the bridge to uh
Kansas I mean uh Kentucky is right
across from Cincinnati it's like we're
sitting here waiting for anybody to
drive up nobody drove up and they ended
up driving me back to the hotel
and then you got easy and Dre what the
[__] was you where'd you go man we all
got citations and we got to come back
here they want us to fly back here to go
to court and they couldn't get they was
looking for you they couldn't catch you
I was like man I did I did
and I'm a dip again next show